this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with prostate cancer
this video will help you understand how
to manage it
prostate cancer is a type of cancer that
forms in a man's prostate gland
most prostate cancer is slow growing and
may not cause any symptoms or problems
however it's very important to have a
follow-up care plan
this includes taking prescribed
medications as directed by your doctor
take note of any side effects and tell
your doctor
ask your doctor what to do if you missed
a dose
if you can't afford your medication
ask your doctor about other options to
get your medications
talk to your doctor before taking
over-the-counter supplements or herbal
medicines
go to all appointments for your doctor's
visits and lab tests
keeping these appointments allows your
doctor to check your condition and see
if you need further treatment
if you have had prostate surgery or
radiation therapy follow any
instructions you are given
you may need to make some of the
following healthy lifestyle changes
don't smoke and limit how much alcohol
you drink
both of these activities may increase
your cancer risk
cut down on salt and foods high in fat
such as fast food
eat a healthy diet with more fruits
vegetables and whole grains
a healthy diet may reduce the risk of
the cancer coming back
become physically active
daily exercise and activities can make
you feel better
keep in mind that some cancer treatments
can make you feel very tired
ask your doctor what you can do to help
you feel less tired
knowing you have cancer can be
overwhelming
you may have worries about things like
your condition and how it affects your
family
treatments and hospital stays
medical bills
and your job
fortunately there are ways to cope with
this
remember that your doctor and health
care team are there to answer any
questions you have
the following sources of support can
help you cope with your concerns
social workers
church leaders
counselors
and support groups
talk to your doctor if you have any
questions about your treatment plan
medications or lifestyle changes to help
you manage prostate cancer